lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
practicar la suma de números de varias
cifras o dígitos pero el objetivo no es
encontrar el resultado sino comprender
por qué funciona el método que usamos
tenemos 40 mil 762 más 30 mil 473 si
quieren pueden pausar el vídeo y tratar
de resolverlo por su cuenta pero en este
caso quiero que vean primero el vídeo
para comprender cómo funciona este
método vamos a pensar en esto en
términos de la posición de valor
esta cantidad llega a la posición de las
decenas de millar así que tenemos
decenas de millar millares centenas
decenas y unidades hacemos una pequeña
tabla aquí y vamos a expresar cada uno
de estos números en decenas de millar
millares centenas decenas y unidades al
mismo tiempo vamos a usar el método
tradicional o algoritmo estándar
algoritmo es una palabra elegante para
referirnos a un sistema o una forma de
resolver algo primero expresamos estos
números en las columnas aquí tenemos
cuatro decenas de millar en ésta
una ponemos 1 2 3 4 en este otro número
tenemos 3 decenas de millas 1 2 3
después vamos a sumar lo que hay en esta
columna en ambos números tengo cero
millares así que dejamos vacía esta
columna
aquí tenemos siete centenas uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis y siete y en este
número tenemos cuatro centenas 1 2 3 y 4
pasamos a la columna de las decenas y en
este número tenemos seis decenas uno dos
tres cuatro cinco y seis y en este otro
número tenemos siete decenas uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis y siete
finalmente aquí tenemos dos unidades 1 2
y aquí 3 unidades 1 2 y 3 vamos a
reescribir de nuevo este número de acá
tenemos 4 decenas de millar 40.000 luego
tenemos 7 centenas lo escribimos tenemos
6 decenas y finalmente dos unidades
simplemente estoy volviendo a escribir
el número pero con el color que
representa cada posición de valor esto y
esto otro son los
formas de representar el mismo número
reescribimos también este número de acá
tres decenas de millar y cero millares
luego tenemos cuatro centenas después
tenemos siete decenas y finalmente tres
unidades
ahora vamos a sumar lo que tenemos aquí
y también vamos a sumar lo que tenemos
acá normalmente comenzamos en la
posición de menor valor dos unidades más
tres unidades son cinco unidades de
forma similar dos unidades más tres
unidades son 1 2 3 4 y 5 unidades vamos
bien veamos la posición de las decenas
en la posición de las decenas tenemos
seis decenas más siete decenas
normalmente decimos que tenemos trece
decenas pero trece decenas es lo mismo
que tres decenas y una centena así que
lo que hacemos es reagrupar ponemos aquí
las tres decenas y acá ponemos la
centena a veces las personas dicen que
llevan un 1 ponemos el 3 y llevamos un 1
que ponemos aquí parece magia pero lo
que hacemos es tomar 10 escenas y las
agrupamos en la posición de las centenas
aquí se verá más claramente tenemos seis
decenas más siete decenas las sumamos y
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 y 13
decenas lo que hacemos aquí es ver que
todo esto nos da una centena y tres
decenas por lo que ponemos aquí la
centena y escribimos el 3 en las decenas
que tenemos en la posición de las
centenas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 y 12 lo
escribimos aquí abajo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 y 12 aquí sucede lo mismo que en
las decenas no tenemos un dígito que
represente el 12 en nuestro sistema
numérico así que tomamos 10 de estos y
nos convertimos en un millar que
pondremos en esta columna y ahora de
este lado hacemos lo mismo 17 más 4 es
12 son 12 centenas ponemos dos centenas
más un millar en la posición de los
millares tenemos 1
pero igual a uno igual de este lado
tenemos un millar finalmente en la
posición de las decenas de millas cuatro
decenas de millar más tres decenas de
millar nos da siete decenas de millar lo
mismo pasa de este lado 43 nos da uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis y siete
decenas de millar
el resultado es 71 mil 235 lo mismo
queda de este lado 71 mil 235 espero que
con esto hayan comprendido mejor cómo
estas dos representaciones funcionan no
es que mágicamente llevemos números de
un lado a otro sino que representamos
los mismos números de distintas formas
con esto terminamos